OBS Source?
Hallo?
OBS?
Was jetzt?
Geht's jetzt wieder?
Was war denn das?
Wo da vorne war das wieder, ha?
ich würde sagen wo da vorne wieder zugeschlagen
die dji ist jetzt wie spricht man die eigentlich richtig aus
ja heute morgen habe ich sie noch gelobt
ok gucken wir kommen jetzt das video erst mal fertig
ganz auf die gier reagierte auf den bericht zunächst nennen wir es optimistisch die
unternehmenssprecherin teilte sie wird mit das problem sei bereits behoben und das ungefähr
30 Minuten bevor der Entdecker live demonstrierte, dass tausende Roboter noch immer auf seine Befehle
reagierten. Der erste Patch vom 8. Februar war offenbar nicht auf allen Servern ausgerollt
worden. Am 10. Februar folgte ein zweites Update, das die Lücke laut DJI vollständig geschlossen
hat. Der Hersteller betont, es habe sich nur um ein theoretisches Potenzial für unberechtigten
Zugriff auf Kamerabilder gehandelt und es gebe keine Hinweise auf einen breiteren Missbrauch.
Ja, als würde das irgendwie gelockt werden.
Die Nachrichten sind halt da.
Das steht doch in keinem Log drin.
Wie das mit Kamerabildern funktioniert,
hätte mich allerdings in der Tat interessiert.
Die werden ja wohl kaum Kamerabild-Streaming
über MQTT machen, oder?
Oder?
Machen die irgendwelches Motion-JPG
über...
äh, MQTT oder, oder?
Dir trauscht das alles zu.
... hat The Verge von mindestens zwei weiteren Problemen berichtet, die noch nicht behoben sind.
Eines davon, eine Möglichkeit, den Pinschutz der Kamera zu umgehen, wurde öffentlich gemacht.
Eine zweite Sicherheitslücke, die als ernsthaft eingestuft wird, hält The Verge auf Bitten der Forscher noch zurück, bis DJI nachgebessert hat.
Was bedeutet das jetzt für euch?
Zunächst, wenn ihr einen DJI Romo habt, ist die bekannte Lücke laut Hersteller gepatcht.
Ihr müsst nichts tun, das Update kam automatisch über die Cloud.
Aber das Grundproblem bleibt.
Saugroboter mit Kameras sind Wanzen auf Rädern in eurer Wohnung.
Wenn Hersteller bei der Server sich halt schlampen und die Geschichte zeigt...
Ja, deswegen finde ich diese Sache mit alles in die Cloud halt echt für den Arsch, ja.
Drei Lehren aus dem Fall, okay.
Dieser Fall ist interessant gleich aus drei Gründen.
Erstens, eine massive Sicherheitslücke wurde nicht von einem Profi-Hacker entdeckt,
sondern von jemandem, der nur mit seinem Staubsauger spielen wollte, mit KI-Unterstützung.
Das zeigt, wie niedrig die Hürden inzwischen sind.
Das wäre in Deutschland schon wieder krasse Hacker-Geschichte.
Ich meine, PHP My Admin zu verwenden, ist ja auch schon ein Hacker-Tool-Einsatz.
Da helfen natürlich auch KI-Tools wie Cloud Code, die eben frei verfügbar sind.
Der Kreis derer, die die Lücken entdecken können, wird dadurch größer.
Und es sind nicht immer nur Leute, die damit, wie in diesem Fall jetzt geschehen, hilfreich für die Betroffenen umgehen.
Zweitens, das eigentliche Problem.
Fehlende Zugriffskontrolle auf Cloud-Servern ist ein klassischer, seit Jahren bekannter Fehler, den Hersteller immer noch machen.
Und drittens zeigt es, dass TLS-Verschlüsselung als Prädikat auf dem Karton...
Ach stimmt, die sind pleite, die Leute. Wie hießen die nochmal?
Modern Solutions, genau.
...kein Freifahrtschein ist.
Im Ergebnis brauchen wir dringend verbindliche Mindeststandards für IoT-Sicherheit.
Ja, als würden sich die China-Chinesen daran halten.
Das kannst du klicken, ja.
Die sagen dann einfach, wenn einer sagt, ja, aber eure Geräte müssen verbindliche IoT-Standards einhalten,
da sagen die dann einfach...
...und machen weiter.
Das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Im Zweifelsfall drucken die sich so ein Zertifizierungsetikett selber aus und drucken es drauf.
Das interessiert die China-Chinesen nicht.
Wollen wir mal kurz Package-Updates.
Warum? Weil es geht.
Weil Arch Linux, by the way.
Siehste? Arch Linux.
Was benutze ich eigentlich? BPF hier.
Warum ist das installiert?
JetBrains Toolbox muss auch geupdatet werden und JetBrain IDE's auch.
vor updates gibt keine updates im haus spackt manchmal echt richtig rum ich
muss übrigens anwendungen schließen noch richtig merken was ist bpf damit kannst
du relativ mit relativ wenig overhead netzwerk traffic abgreifen und damit
dann sachen anstellen also ganz viel im kuba nettes umfeld basiert auf bpf und
Das heißt ja eigentlich genau genommen eBPF.
Extended Backlit Packet Filter.
Ist eine revolutionäre Linux-Kernel-Technologie.
Echtzeitüberwachung, Netzwerk, Performance-Optimierung, Sicherheitstracing.
Ach, das ist im Moment eBPF.
Das ist was anderes als BPF.
Nee, oder?
Ich habe gedacht, es ist das gleiche.
Naja.
Gucken wir mal, was das hier sagt.
BPF-Tools.
Das ist auch sehr aussagekräftig.
Warum müsste man das irgendwie erklären,
was das für eine Abkürzung ist?
Es juckt ja nicht.
Der ist gut, der UM-790.
Was ist denn da für eine GPU drin?
Du bekommst nur 10
Was ist denn da drin?
Moment, wartet mal
Also hier
Ich habe mir die Minisauberuhr mit 790 geholt
Und das gleiche habe ich mit Ulama in LXC gemacht
mit Lama 3 bekomme
ich nur 10 Tokens pro Sekunde, während du
18 bekommen hattest. Liegt das am Single Channel?
Ne, glaube ich nicht. Und hast du
das Problem mit Ulama und GPU-Hängen gelöst?
Ähm,
ja, ich hab
dem mehr RAM gegeben, der
GPU.
Mehr VRAM
vom RAM abgezwackt. Das hat anscheinend geholfen.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Wir kaufen Zeug ein.
Ähm, und
ansonsten, bist du dir
sicher, dass dein
Olamar
auch
die GPU benutzt?
Weil 10 Tokens
hatte ich auch, als es 100%
CPU war.
Olamar zeigt 100%
GPU.
Okay, und was hast du?
Was hast du?
Hast du auch eine Radeon 780M?
Und ein 8-Kern-Ryzen.
Also wie das NAS.
Witzigerweise hat der Mini-PC hier, ne?
Der Mini-PC und das NAS haben fast 1 zu 1 die gleichen Specs.
Ich muss noch kurz Dark Breeder.
das ist das sonst sonst riecht durch mit der zeit ja viel angenehmer gleich viel
angenehmer
Den gab es mit 32, ich meine, allein schon 32 Gig kosten ja teilweise fast schon so viel.
Also, 32 Gig und die SSD ist ja fast teurer.
Du hast ja die Hardware umsonst gekriegt fast, oder?
Nein, Terabyte SSD, was kosten die? 150 Euro oder sowas?
Und 32 Gig RAM kosten was? 400 Euro?
Was ist eigentlich das Symbol neben U-Block Origin?
Das da?
Das ist für Twitch Emotes.
Twitch Emotes. Ah Leute, Leute, das haben wir lange nicht mehr. Das hatten wir lange nicht mehr.
Twitch Emote Song.
Aber vorher will ich mir nochmal kurz hier das, die Specs angucken.
Wo ist das so günstig?
Achso, weil das wahrscheinlich komplett nackig ist, ne?
7, 9, 4, 0, HS, richtiger HS der Prozessor.
Was hab ich?
Ich hab ein 7, 8, 4 HS.
Also eine Generation älter.
Moment, Leute, ich muss das ausmachen.
Da kennt man ja nicht.
Und wo seh ich jetzt, was es kosten würde?
Ach, da oben. 799.
Eine ältere HS, ja.
Aber
das geht
eigentlich klar. Guck mal.
Geizhals. Das ist bestimmt
SO-DIMM oder so
RAM, ne?
Arbeitsspeicher.
DDR5.
SO-DIMM.
32 Gig.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt, das kostet nicht 400 Euro
Das kostet nur 289 Euro
SSD kostet nochmal 150
Ja gut
Holst du dir einen neuen PC? Nö, warum?
Hat nur grad jemand im Chat gepostet
Ist doch teuer
aber leute er so viel rahmen habe ich dem gar nicht gegeben wie viel wie viel rahmen hat meiner
jetzt gerade meinen meinen meine nasskiste moment ich habe das noch an wir können mal kurz gucken
2 punkt mv top 2 gig würde ich mal sagen
2 gig memory rocken
kann er auch absolute zahlen ansatz 3 prozent belegt schreiben
Es kann aber eigentlich nicht sein
Dass du weniger hast
Du hast eine bessere CPU und die gleiche GPU
Das ist sehr merkwürdig
Hast du andere Models benutzt?
Aber gut, wenn du weniger RAM hast
Aber solange dein Model in RAM passt
Ist alles gut, ja
Ich glaube nicht, dass das an Dual Channel
und Dingsbums Channel liegt
Mein RAM taktet auch nur
mit 4800, deiner ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch
schneller, ach keine Ahnung
aber es ist nett
So, Moment Leute
das muss jetzt mal wieder sein
komplett random, ich weiß
aber ich brauche jetzt
den Kokona Song
Kekona.
Der Kekona-Song will nicht.
Hallo?
how to spell that
now we're older
everyone's moved on
but I remember
twitch chat
from days long gone
twitchy moans
from long ago
made you feel
you're not alone
Kappa PogChamp
People, forehead, Bible thumb, twitchy modes.
I remember typing dance games, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy
Spamming all the time
TOS was nowhere
So everyone's feeling fine
Twitch Emotes
Long ago
Make you feel
You're not alone
Kappa Pock Champ
People forehead
Da fragen wir Z.
Um yes today.
Yesterday.
Twitchy Moles, long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Pog is PogChamp, Cap is Capa, Bible Thumb.
Twitchy Molds
Paper Hands
Bible Thumb
Twitchy Molds
gesorgt sport richter poggers song
im wort kann man das wahrscheinlich sehen was denn
was kann man sehen im wort
nicht sehen doch doch das kannst du im wort sehen ich habe keine extra audio
spur ich mache ja keine copyright musik aus an den tenor jährige musik
gerade dabei sind ist das hier überhaupt noch aktuell er applaudiert dann noch
ab und zu jemand oder kein stream vor einem jahr mehr anscheinend nicht aber
macht ja auch nichts also wobei das eigentlich noch mal mit backup auf
YouTube echt ganz nice ist,
falls mal das andere Archiv wegfliegt.
Okay.
So, also Chat,
auf geht's. Ich habe mir hier einen
Einkaufszettel geschrieben.
Wo habe ich es hier?
Da.
Na, gucken wir mal.
Wird das Archiv eigentlich gehostet?
Ich glaube bei Hetzner.
Der Serious Max kümmert sich da drum
Aber ich glaube bei Hetzner
Und die Domains
Die bezahle ich
Also es lief mal beim
Sebarro auf irgendeiner ollen Kiste
im Keller, der viel RAM hatte.
Ist nicht .tv richtig teuer.
Ne, die habe ich recht günstig gekriegt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da im Jahr für bezahle,
aber es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Ach, guck mal, da gibt es sogar eine eigene
Stats-Seite.
Worts
Clips
gestreamt
7,5 terabyte ist das archiv groß die datenbank ist nur 3,8 gig oder 3,9 gig
das automatisch mit whisper transcribe das auch um mehr der programmer
Der Chainlore.
Leider ist er gebannt mittlerweile, der Chainlore.
Warum du da bist ja anscheinend.
Schreibst du viele Chatnachrichten.
Ich kann den nicht anbannen.
Ich hab den nicht gebannt.
Der ist auf Twitch gebannt.
Twitch hat seinen Account gelöscht.
Wer weiß, was er wieder für ASCII Dickpics oder so gepostet hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab den noch nicht gebannt.
Er ist ja mittlerweile wieder da,
aber ich hab den neuen Namen vergessen irgendwie.
Und er ergibt sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu erkennen,
weil er sonst denkt, er wird wieder gebannt.
Ach, guck mal, was haben wir denn da?
Das Emote, Leute, das Emote wird eindeutig
zu wenig verwendet.
Geht's dir generell eigentlich wieder besser?
Also man muss sagen, mir geht's
jetzt rein halb monate ziemlich lange okay ja zu den letzten zwei wochen ist
wieder ein bisschen schlechter aber dass das läuft halt immer so ein bisschen in
wellen da kannst nichts machen
Oh, Music.
Leute, ich hab noch über 21 Emotes,
die ich reinhauen kann.
Ich muss da echt,
da muss was gemacht werden.
Wir brauchen mehr Fail Emotes.
Okay.
Ich brauche, ich brauche gut, wir brauchen vor allem neue Subscriber Badges.
Und von welchen Services kommt ihr heute weg?
Beim Digital Independence Day ist das heute.
Ich bin bei so vielen Services wie möglich schon cloudtechnisch weg.
Was mir gerade auffällt ist
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht erinnern
Aber wir haben ein C++
Ein Weeb C++ Emote
Warum haben wir das denn
haben aber glaube ich aber aber glaube ich schon eine weile da gibt es übrigens ein ganzes
ganzes github repo girls holding programming books github irgendwie so anime girls holding
Programming Box.
Ich glaube,
der Dark Reader spinnt hier gerade ein bisschen rum.
Äh.
Okay, whatever.
Was ist denn das?
Ja, der Name ist Programm Anime Girls Holding Programming Books.
Ja.
Moment, sind das jetzt wieder neue Bilder gerade?
Oder hatten wir die schon?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ne, das sind wieder neue jetzt, oder?
Whatever.
Was zum...
Okay, ich scroll mal lieber nicht weiter.
Wer weiß, wie Monka Tostas gleich noch wird alles.
Das sieht schon hier teilweise echt
hart an der Grenze wieder aus.
Eieiei.
Gut.
Listening, Leute.
Listening.
Da muss ich jetzt...
Muss ich selbst mal Emotes
schreiben. Listening.
So, was wir kaufen.
Ich habe hier eine Einkaufsliste. Ich bin jetzt schon
fast eine Stunde
online, glaube ich.
und habe nichts gekauft weil ich wieder zu am schwätzen ich habe eine einkaufsliste gemacht
so und das erste und wahrscheinlich auch gleichermaßen langweiligste
der netzwerkkabel ich brauche unbedingt und also mal man ordentlich ist set wieder ich habe so
richtig billige Netzwerkkabel hier nur am Start.
Also ich habe ein paar ganz gute.
Die sind relativ kurz. Die habe ich alle schon im Einsatz.
Und ich habe ein gutes
15 Meter Kabel.
So. Fertig. Sonst habe ich nix.
Nur Schrott.
Stimmt, FS.com habt ihr gesagt.
Was kostet der Versand von
FS.com nach Deutschland?
Produkte.
Vernetzung. LWL-Kabel.
Ne. Vernetzung?
Wo muss ich denn da hin?
wir lassen da wieder an wir haben lager in deutschland ok produkte
vernetzung
neben die kabel von equip bei denen habe ich schon mal was bestellt aber seht ihr
seht ihr hier irgendwelche kabel lwl kabel sehe ich nur
Kupfer-Systeme?
Kupfer-Patch-Kabel.
Sind das denn auch die guten Stecker?
Ja, das sind die nicen Stecker.
Wo man hinten drauf drücken kann
und vorne geht's raus.
Was viel praktischer ist, als die, wo du wirklich vorne
immer drücken musst, je nach Gehäuse.
Es gibt Kart 8, ja.
theoretisch ist card 8 sogar glaube ich bis 25 gig zugelassen
aber mehr als egal ganz ehrlich ich glaube mehr als 25 gig werden wir nicht
mehr sehen über kupfer also über klassische twisted pair kupferkabel das
klappt jetzt schon richtig
Nee.
Für 25 Gig?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Welche Kabel
für 25...
Ja, genau.
Du brauchst Cut-Up.
Dachte ich mir eigentlich auch.
Ach, du meinst zu Hause.
Leute, wir müssen jetzt doch mal
den Dark Reader ausmachen.
Auch sorry, wenn es jetzt hier...
Wie kurz ist dieses Kabel?
Das ist 15 Zentimeter oder sowas.
Ja, 15.
15 Zentimeter.
Das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen kurz.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich hätte gerne so ein ordentliches Sortiment.
So, keine Ahnung.
10 Stück 30 Zentimeter.
10 Stück 1,50 oder sowas.
Die haben auch Sets.
Okay, exzellent.
UTP?
Nee, ich will nicht UTP.
Ich will SFTP.
Kann man da auswählen?
Ähm, ist das der Querschnitt
von den
Adern oder was?
Oder wie ist das hier?
Von den Adern oder vom gesamten Kabel?
Vom Kabel, ne?
Weil von den Adern, das wäre ganz schön fett.
das kabel okay wir machen was anderes hier anzahl 24 pro packung beim gibt es
nur in einer farbe und er bleibt ja bleibt ja eigentlich nur dass sie
übrig aber wenn es in 24 24 15 was ist eine gute länge 1,5 meter ich weiß nicht
Was?
Kabelscheune.
Da habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Netzwerk, Technik und Elektromaterial bei Kabelscheune.
Ein CAT 8.1 Patchkabel.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Ich will keinen 25 Gig machen.
Kabel und Leitung.
Kabelscheune.
Die kenne ich nicht.
Netzwerk, wow, wow
Netz, Patchkabel
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Patchkabel
Und Netzwerkkabel
Netzwerkkabel ist das, wo du selbst Stecker drauf machen musst
Oder?
Okay, Chat, Chat
Jetzt mal im Ernst
Das ist doch, achso
Das ist deutlich dicker, okay
Also, das Ding ist ja
Wenn ich nicht so faul wäre
Könnte ich mir immer
Perfekt lange, genau für das was ich brauche
Netzwerkkabel
Machen, indem ich selbst Stecker
Drauf mache, aber da bin ich einfach
Zu faul für, ich seh es nicht ein
Irgendwas selbst zu krimpen, das ist mir auch immer viel zu fuddelig
Gerade wenn du mal mehr als eins machen musst
Er selber knippt ein Fakt ab, ich weiß.
Was ist?
Super Flexkabel.
Flache Kabel?
Davon habe ich tatsächlich noch zwei Stück hier.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen,
Outdoor brauchen wir nicht.
Cat 8 muss es auch nicht sein.
Chat.
Cat 6a, oder?
Dürfte wahrscheinlich preis-leistungsmäßig mit das Beste sein.
Die machen doch auch 10 Gig, oder?
Gibt auch bessere Stecker plus Keystone.
Ja, sowas hab ich.
Aber du musst es ja immer noch auflegen auf den Dingern.
Ich weiß, was du meinst, ja?
Du meinst diese Dinger, die du so zusammenklappst dann.
Aber du musst ja die Kabel immer noch reinfuddeln.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe auch ganz billige Kabel hier, teilweise uralt.
Wahrscheinlich auch Cat5-Kabel.
Da geht auch 10 Gig.
Aber man muss sagen, es ist nicht zertifiziert für 10 Gig.
Aber es geht.
Aber das ist auch nur ungefähr einen Meter lang oder sowas.
Ja, also die Dinger sind in der Tat gar nicht schlecht
Ähm, hier
Keystone, AJ45
Davon hab ich sogar noch ein paar da
Das funktioniert
Das ist eigentlich richtig, richtig nice
Also wenn man, wenn man was selbst macht
Dann
Dann so
Mets Connect
Was ist das denn?
Habe ich noch nie gehört
Ah, das ist auch sowas ähnliches
Ja, das ist doch sehr ähnlich
Hier
So, warte mal
Hier sieht man es, glaube ich
Genau, so sieht das Ding aus
hier, äh, hallo?
Das Video ist einfach nur schlecht geschnitten.
Okay, das Video ist einfach nur schlecht.
Guck mal, hier legst du das so drauf, ja.
Nee, du legst das hier rein,
das Kabel, ja,
die legst du hier so rein und dann drückst du es da rein,
dann schneidet sich das ins Kabel
und dann klappst du das hier zu und dann drückt es
das komplett runter.
Geh mal davon aus, jetzt sieht man es auch hier,
wie das funktioniert. Aber allein schon,
da drauf habe ich keinen Bock.
Chat, allein schon da drauf
habe ich keinen Bock. Stell dir mal vor, da müsst
er acht Kabel machen.
Da sei er am Kotzen.
Also nachmessen will ich nicht.
Jetzt musst du dir die richtige Farbe raussuchen
In der Hoffnung
Dein Kabel hat ordentliche Farbkodierung
Was das Ding hier nett hat
Das hat einfach nur immer Farbe plus Weiß
Es gibt auch andere Kabel
Die haben
Weiß plus Orange
Dass du es besser findest
Chat
Was benutzt ihr für Kabel
welche die verdrillt sind mit weiß und farbe oder welche die weiß mit farbe haben
da ist ganz schön die farbe drauf okay ich sehe es da nicht diese doch an der
verdrillung jede muss den kram ja aufmachen dann auf die richtige sache drauf legen und so
jetzt hast du es ja auseinander dann findest du es dann gar nicht mehr richtig
Übrigens
Der nervigen Part, die Gabel da drauf zu legen
Hat er jetzt mal einfach übersprungen
Genau, jetzt drückst du es rein
Und jetzt machst du diese Klappe zu
Und das drückt es richtig fest
Und jetzt kannst du hinten noch, wenn du ganz furchtbar ordentlich bist
Kannst du hinten noch einen Kabelbinder drumherum machen?
Kannst du dir aber auch schenken.
Ja, doch, der macht noch einen Kabelbinder drum.
Das ist halt richtig nice, ja.
Moment, war das überhaupt der richtige
Connector, den wir da gesehen haben?
Nee, das ist falsch.
Guck mal, das ist der...
Egal.
Du hast letztens die genommen, die waren komfi.
Okay.
Ja, das ist ja auch sowas ähnliches.
Aber es ist ganz schön teuer.
13 Euro für vier so kleine Stecker.
Äh, das mache ich nicht.
Da kaufe ich mir lieber eine Packung Kabel.
Für das Geld kann ich mir wahrscheinlich
Jetzt wenn wir mal bei Amazon gucken
Ähm
Hier so ein Netzwerkkabel bei Amazon
Da gibt es manchmal so Sets
Äh
Farbig
Da gibt es manchmal so Sets
Sowas hier in der Richtung
Da kriegst du
Guck mal das sind
Wie viele sind das?
Zehn Stück, naja.
War nicht billig.
Aber immerhin, zehn Kabel, bei den anderen kriegst du nur vier Stecker.
Haben die auch Sets?
Haben die hier auch Sets?
Dass man zum Beispiel sagen kann, ey, ich hätte gerne fünf Stück von jeder Farbe in dieser Länge oder sowas.
Profi-Patch, was es
in die alles gibt.
Weiß, noch nie.
Nie benutzt.
Die Webseite gefällt mir nicht.
Hier gibt es sieben verschiedene Farben.
Chat, ich oute mich jetzt mal als übelster Kack-Noob.
Was sind eigentlich spezifikationsmäßig der Unterschied zwischen Cat 6 und Cat 6a?
Das war was, was weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf.
Halogenfreie Kabel.
Es gibt Kabel, da ist Halogen drin.
Überall ist Halogen drin.
Echt?
Also ich kenne das nur bei den
Wahrscheinlich dann Verlegekabel
Da ist so
Weißes Pulver drinne
Und jetzt nicht Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof
Weißes Pulver
So Talg oder sowas in der Richtung
Dass die Kabel quasi wenn du sie biegst
Nicht kaputt gehen
Innen drinne
Kennt ihr das?
So diese
Weiße Pulver was da in den Kabeln drin ist
in diesem verleger kabel
fertig muss man brötchen nebenbei essen
ok das ist ja was
scheiß mal drauf
kabel werde ich heute nicht werde ich heute nicht einig
wir müssen uns jetzt mal wie ich weiß
aber heute sei es ein es sei zu trecken streamen
wir kaufen gleich weiter ein
oder auch nicht ich hab los bis bis bis 19 30 Zeit auch
wir müssen jetzt jetzt mal kurz Video angucken weil
ich muss unbedingt was futtern ich habe mehr Hunger
und ich hab jetzt hier gerade Sandwich Maker Toastbrote stehen
und Sandwich Maker Toastbrote sind schon extrem
Pog
Und...
Nein!
Jetzt nicht.
Komm, wir gucken uns...
Was drin ist Salami?
Komm, wir gucken uns das CD3003-Video an.
Oh ne, das ist...
Oh, Vibe-Coding-Video!
Moment!
Was?
BTF?
Ne, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Was zum Teufel?
Was haltet ihr davon?
wir gucken uns das C++ Flame Video an.
Wir wollten uns das eh angucken.
Oder erstmal Fire Ship.
Das Problem ist, wenn ich mit dem
C++ Flame Video anfange,
dann kann ich nicht essen,
weil dann muss ich alle 15 Sekunden anhalten
und mich aufregen.
C++ Flame.
Okay, während ich esse, gucken wir uns das C++ Flame an.
Ähm, aber Chat,
ich weiß nicht, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal von vorne anfangen
und uns aufschreiben, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Das ist übrigens ein richtig gutes Video.
Das wirkt erstmal wie so ein satirisches
Ich flame es zu Tode Video,
aber der hat recht, komplett recht.
Wir wissen alle, C++ ist die beschissenste Programmiersprache,
die keine beschissene Programmiersprache sein will.
Ja, es gibt Sachen wie Brainfuck, die wollen beschissen sein.
Aber C++ ist beschissen, aber möchte nicht beschissen sein.
Und so alte Sachen wie COBOL oder FORTRAN,
ja, die sind auch beschissen und möchten nicht beschissen sein,
aber die wurden seit was weiß ich wie vielen Jahren
nicht mehr großartig erweitert.
C++ wird laufend erneuert, erweitert.
Oh, guck mal, ist euch was aufgefallen?
Es ist jetzt um 18 Uhr, hat der Dark Mode
angemacht. Guck mal, der hat Dark Mode
eingeschaltet auf KDE.
Pog.
Äh.
Moment, was war die Frage?
Chat, weiß jemand,
wo es diese Knickschutzdinger
gibt, also ohne Kabel halt.
Haskell. Ja, das checken nur Leute,
die IQ von 160
plus haben.
Also sind wir nicht mal weit entfernt, Chat.
Bei so vielen
Subscriptions, wie es heute gegeben hat.
Was meinst du denn für Dinge, die...
Was ist daran jetzt so besonders?
Sehen ganz normal aus?
Egal.
C++ Flame, ich muss...
100 Linux Things You Need To Know.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Okay, ihr könnt euch's jetzt aussuchen.
C++ Flame Video
oder FireShip 100 Plus Linux Things You Need To Know.
Linux.
Okay, wir gucken uns Linux an.
Ach, erst mal was nehmen.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile würde ich sagen,
hat das mehr.
Und da ist PewDiePie auch nicht
ganz unschuldig dran.
Aber hauptsächlich
ist Microsoft dran schuld,
weil Microsoft Windows so
schlecht gemacht hat, dass viele Leute einfach
sagen, Alter, ich ertrag es nicht mehr.
Ich hoffe, dass wir Arch-Linux verwenden.
Ach, dafür steht POSIX.
Wusste ich auch nicht.
... would be compatible with each other.
Its influence remains strong today,
with macOS, Android, FreeBSD
and most Linux distros being POSIX-compliant.
In 1987, an OS called Minix for academic use was developed,
but redistribution of its code was restricted.
This inspired a Finnish computer science student
named Linus Torvalds to develop Linux in 1991.
Importantly, it's free open-source software,
licensed under GPL 2.0.
And by free, I mean free as in...
Chat bei Fireship habe ich mittlerweile
den eindruck der hat seine eigene stimme per ki geklaut und spricht die videos gar nicht mehr selbst
mittlerweile freedom it's free to distribute modif and make money off of now what i'm referring to
is linux ist in fact not an operating system moment moment moment chat chat chat allow me
to interject for a moment ist das überhaupt linux reingenommen
Geht mal in euch!
Ist es nicht viel eher GNU slash Linux?
was typisch ein Tool ist, das System D nennt, obwohl Alternativen existieren.
Sobald initialisiert wird, wird der Kernel Applikationen in der User-Base starten,
was typisch den User zu einem Login-Screen bringt.
Als der User anfängt, zu machen, hat der Kernel viele Verantwortung.
Er allociert und deallociert die Erinnerung für Prozesse und
Man ist so ein Kack-Noob wie ich, wobei eigentlich ist das überhaupt nicht noobig.
Ich habe jahrelang keinen Login-Manager benutzt.
Ich habe mich einfach auf der Shell eingeloggt und dann StartX getippt.
Was ja streng genommen gar nicht stimmt bei Intel-CPUs, ne?
Intel-CPU hat ja noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Ring-3 oder irgendwie sowas, weiß nicht, wie es heißt,
für Management-Access und Management-Geschichten.
Was öfters mal Gegenstand von Debatten ist.
AMD hat das auch.
Okay.
Das ist er ja.
Das ist mir neu.
call was made to the kernel which checked permissions and managed drivers to turn those ones
and zeros into pixels on the screen as an end user though i don't care my friend told me about a cool
command called touch but i have no idea what it does the cool thing about linux is that you can
pull up the manual for any command by hitting up my main man man it looks like this command is used
to create a new file man isn't that cool let's go ahead and try it out now by creating a new text
file it looks like nothing happened but i promise it worked i can prove it by using the ls command to
die File in dieser Direktorie auszuzeichnen. Und da ist es. Und wir können die File-Kontente mit dem
CAT-Kommand lesen. Aber wiederum passiert nichts, weil es keine Daten in diesem File gibt.
Aber es gibt eine Menge Metadaten, wie Timestamps, die wir mit dem Stat-Kommand
beitragen können. Das Stat-Kommand riecht mit CAT und wenn wir es runieren, wissen wir, dass dieses File
Birth Time, wann es modifiziert wurde und wann es zuletzt eingeführt wurde. Das ist nützlich, aber wir
können auch mehr Informationen vom LS-Kommand erhalten, indem wir Fläge hinzufügen, wie die L-Flagge, um mehr
Details zu listen.
ls minus lacht.
Hö, beste.
List, reverse, human readable, all, reverse.
Details and the h-flag to make them human readable.
When we run that command, we can now see the exact size of every file.
And we can also combine flags in Linux.
Chatge, schock mal den Michael nicht so.
Da wird nichts passieren. Das ist überhaupt nichts Wildes.
Was meinst du, wie viele Insekten einen schon da gebissen haben, ohne dass was passiert ist?
In Deutschland haben wir ja nichts Schlimmes, Gefährliches.
Wenn du jetzt in Australien gewesen wärst oder so, ja, dann ist was anderes.
Aber hier, hier gibt es ja weder was Giftiges noch irgendwas Gefährliches.
Bracket, to redirect its output to a new
climate.
Macht's möglich, Chat. Stimmt, das ist der erste so richtig für mich persönlich greifende Grund, wo ich sagen würde, ich möchte keine großen Spinnen hier haben.
Wir sollten vielleicht was gegen die Klimaerwärmung tun.
Ja, also dass es vielleicht ganz gut ist, wenn nicht tausende Leute sterben müssen und so, das ist zwar auch nicht verkehrt, ja.
Aber so für mich persönlich, dass das Argument, eklige Spinnen aus Australien haben wir dann hier, zieht, zieht tatsächlich.
Das will ich nicht. Aber ich bin ja eh schon recht klimaneutral unterwegs.
Sofern möglich, ja.
Dann bin ich wirklich klimaneutral.
Aber wo es geht, wo es geht, ja.
Aber ich bin sonst mittlerweile sogar ein Elektroauto.
another command. Like for example, if we
have a log file of our broken code,
we might first use cat to read that file,
but then we could pipe the output to sort,
which would sort it line by line,
and then unique to remember.
Ist nicht bald wieder Earth
Overshoot Day oder wie das heißt?
Das ist doch immer früher
jetzt im Jahr. Also quasi
der Tag, wo die
Menschheit die Ressourcen
verbraucht hat, die die Erde natürlich
quasi in der Zeit generieren könnte,
regenerieren könnte.
Das heißt, alles andere fliegt weg.
Das ist doch immer, das wird doch immer früher im Jahr.
Und das ist, ich weiß genau, wie das dieses Jahr wieder sein wird.
Die Leute sagen auf Twitter, oh, ganz schlimm,
ah ja, Forza ist runtergeladen, weiter geht's.
Oder wenn du keine Leben hast, kannst du EMAX probieren.
Aber ich werde dieses File kreieren.
Über gescheite Software beschwere ich mich da nie.
Wir haben so viel Crap installiert auf diesen Windows-Kästen,
da kann das ein oder andere Gescheite auch mal drauf sein.
Aber ich werde trotzdem kein Emacs unter Windows benutzen.
Aber das Beste,
Chat, es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich mittlerweile bei den meisten Bash-Skripts mache. Das ist DNAME, Dollar, Null, Blub, irgendwas am Anfang. CD, DNAME, Dollar, Null, glaube ich ist es. Das wechselt immer in das Verzeichnis rein, in dem das Skript selber liegt.
Das ist natürlich nichts, was man immer machen muss, aber wenn man ein Skript hat, was automatisiert irgendwas machen soll, relativ zu sich selbst, ist das Beste.
Und dann sette ich set-e-x-o-u-pipe-fail, glaube ich.
Der zeigt nämlich genau an, was er macht, jedes einzelne Kommando und bricht bei Fehlern ab und auch bei Fehlern, die in der Pipe auftreten.
Ja, ich glaube, so sieht es aus, Take, wie Akra die hat.
Das meine ich.
Aber am wichtigsten wird es dir zeigen, wie du deinen eigenen virtuellen privaten Server spielst, um deine eigenen Applikationen selbst zu hosten.
Aber ein großer Vorteil des Linux-Users ist, dass er einen krankere, existenzielle Krise schwingt.
Und du kannst dich fragen, wer ich bin.
Wenn du dieses Command beendest, wird es dich wieder komplett in dein Linux-Username zurückgeben.
In der Übung hat es eine unik UID, die mit dem ID-Command beobachtet werden kann.
Mein ID ist 1000, aber es gibt einen besonderen User mit einem UID von 0,
namens Root, aka Admin, Superuser oder Daddy.
Root hat das höchste Niveau von Privilegien und man kann den Root-User mit dem SU-Kommand
oder einen Command mit Sudo auswählen, um es mit elevativen Privilegien zu runten.
Jede User kann mit Sudo-Privilegien gewonnen werden und man kann jetzt
Ihr Privilegien durch Run Sudo-Flag L checken.
In Ergänzung von Users hat Linux auch Gruppen.
Gruppen haben Gruppen-IDs und machen es einfacher,
die Ermessungen für mehrere User zu vermitteln.
Bevor wir über die Ermessensmöglichkeiten sprechen,
schauen wir uns den Filesystem an.
Im Grunde genommen sind wir in unserer Home-Direktorie,
die wie ein persönlicher Workspace für den User ist,
den du in den Filesystem eingeloggt hast.
Wir könnten hier eine neue Direktorie machen,
mit dem Make-Dir-Kommand,
dann CD verwenden, um Direktoren zu ändern.
Nun verwenden wir PWD, um die aktuellen funktionierenden Direktoren zu printen.
Aber jetzt gehen wir außerhalb unseres Hauses
in die Rute des Filesystems,
indem wir CD-Slasher verwenden.
Wenn du hier LS klickst,
findest du eine Menge kritische Direktoren,
die du wissen musst.
Wie Boot, der den Linux-Kernel selbst enthält.
Dev enthält externen Geräte wie Harddrüben, ETC enthält Konfigurationsfile und VAR enthält Logfile.
Die interessanteste Direktorie hier ist bin, die eure Binarien hält, und spin für Systembinarien.
Sie sehen, wenn Sie ein Command wie ls runtern, sucht Linux für eine exekutierbare Binarie auf Ihrem System, um zu exekutieren.
Die Sache ist, dass Binarien nicht nur hier leben, sondern auch unter der User-System-Resources-Direktorie und potenziell wo auch immer Sie auf dem Filesystem wollen.
Und das stellt die Frage, wie weiß Linux, wo man den richtigen Binary finden kann?
Nun, da kommt Path rein.
Es ist eine spezielle Umgebungsvariable, die Paths zu Direktoren mit Kolen beinhaltet.
Wenn man ein Command einstellt, wird Linux durch den Path suchen, um einen Binary zu finden.
echt. Wobei auf der VM weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Das ist gar keine VM. Das sieht mittlerweile schon
geht eigentlich. Das sah schon mal schlimmer aus.
Silicon Valley?
Nee, habe ich nicht geguckt. Wo ich mal angefangen habe zu gucken ist
Oh, wie hieß das?
die im Keller bei irgendeiner Versicherung arbeiten oder so.
Und dann eine neue Chefin kriegen.
Kein Schimmer.
Kein Schimmer mehr, wie das hieß.
Das fand ich aber so cringe.
IT-Crowd, genau, ja.
Das hab ich aber nur ein paar Folgen geguckt.
Das fand ich so cringe und nervig.
Das konnte ich mir nicht lange geben.
Und irgendwie finde ich, weiß ich nicht.
Ich fahre dich jetzt auch nicht so zum Weg-Kek-W.
Okay, Chad, ich schreibe es mir mal auf.
So.
Okay.
Ich bin fertig essen.
Dann würde ich sagen, nutzen wir mal die letzten
50 Minuten.
Ungefähr. Plus, minus. Keine Ahnung.
Nutzen wir die mal, um das zu machen,
was ich eigentlich machen wollte,
nämlich was einkaufen.
Äh.
Welches Video hatte ich denn jetzt hier heute
für die Musik?
Alter.
Äh.
Okay.
Irgendwas mit Happy.
Hieß das Happy?
Das da.
Garuda Linux.
Hab ich noch nie.
Ist das das mit auf MixOS Basis?
wo alles immutable ist?
Oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Wenn das das nicht ist, dann hab ich keine Ahnung.
Arch-based?
Noch ein Arch-based, okay.
Oh ja, also nächste.
Hier Leute, ich mach mal kurz den
den Dark-Mode mal wieder aus.
Nicht den Dark-Mode,
den Night Mode mache ich mal wieder aus.
Also, Einkaufsliste.
Das Netzwerk Kabel lasse ich mal.
Da werde ich mal in Ruhe gucken.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich auch langweilig.
So, was ich dann unbedingt
auf nächsten Fall brauche ist,
ich brauche 8 GB.
Unbedingt nochmal
8 GB.
Für den Mini PC,
auf dem ich hier gerade bin, weil guckt mal.
das Ding hat halt nur
7 Gig frei,
nachdem ich der Grafiker ein bisschen was gegeben hab.
Und das ist einfach
zu wenig. 16 Gig ist okay.
Aber 8,
7 ist zu wenig.
Ach, 8 Gig geht, glaube ich, noch.
8 Gig ist glaube ich noch okay.
Machen wir hier DDR5.
Ist das überhaupt SO dem RAM da drin?
Moment.
Beelink CR7.
Was ist das?
Was kommt denn da für ein...
Was kommt denn da für ein RAM rein?
überhaupt?
S-O-Dim, DDR5.
Okay, DDR5,
S-O-Dim.
Und jetzt, was ist denn das beste
Preis pro Gigabyte?
Okay.
Alter, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Okay, beste Preis pro Gigabyte
ist ein 128G.
Single Dings RAM
für easy
nur 800 Euro.
Das ist ja geschenkt.
Gibt es da vielleicht auch
irgendwie halbwegs normale Größen,
die nicht so teuer sind?
Ich brauche hier nur 8 Gig.
ok schauen wir mal hier kurz die geiz als seite seitdem die die neue gebasst
gebastelt haben blicke ich dadurch erweiterte filter muss ich jetzt machen
genau und jetzt kann ich irgendwo sagen 8 gig seht ihr irgendwo hier acht pro
modul pro kit ja datenmenge pro kit pro modul
78 Euro.
Ja, Chat, das geht schon klar.
Ich meine, das hat mal vor einem Jahr 30 Euro oder irgendwas gekostet, ne?
21, 20, 21 Euro hat das mal gekostet.
Vor nicht ganz einem Jahr.
Aber davon werde ich auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht arm.
Moment.
Das ist G-Bait.
Das kostet gar nicht so wenig
Das ist über Ebay
Das ist doch bestimmt
Okay, okay, lass mal kurz gucken
Ob das irgendein seriöser Shop ist
Pavima Shop
Aber Ebay
Ich habe eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bock auf Ebay
Kann es nicht mal einen gescheiten Shop geben
119 bewertung 100 prozent positiv okay dass das das klingt zumindest schon mal nicht nach scam
es ist nicht viel aber es klingt jetzt auch nicht so ins und beschiss kann man auch sagen
lagernd beim händler dann dann moment da gehen wir noch mal zurück und sagen jetzt lagernd wo
Wo geht das?
Das konnte man doch irgendwie hier einstellen,
lagernd beim Händler.
Ich weiß,
ich finde mich auf der neuen...
Ich finde mich auf der neuen
beliebig... Ach, hier unten.
Der Geizhals ist nicht richtig zurecht.
Ey, das ist das Billigste.
MonkaW.
Hatschat, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube das ist sogar ein ganz brauchbares Angebot hier.
Und das sieht auch nicht nach Ultrascam aus.
Der hat 100%
Letzter Monat
Der verkauft nur so Dinger.
wobei auf ebay habe ich echt kein bock aller und und sonst so dass das nächste
ist halt 16 gig kit geil toll was hältst du davon weiß ich nicht kenne ich nicht
lass mal kurz auf stream aufmachen
gut dass ich es auf stream aufgemacht habe weil ich wurde schon wieder gebaited
Ich würde gerickrolled.
Ah, die Samsung-Kiste.
ist das so teuer man amazon ok 8 gb ddr5 so ddr5 es oben
shopst du auf deiner vm oder bist du mini pc w tf warum ist der schizo teuer starte das verdammte
spiel aller das hier ist gar nicht mal das ist gar nicht so schlecht chat das ist gar nicht mal
so schlecht für den 16 g kit das ist ein ein ramm riegel ja okay das ist es aber trotzdem ist das
geht 175 ist halt auch ich weiß das ist jetzt so als ich habe genug kohle für sowas ja aber mich
fragt trotzdem ab ok ich heiße aufkommen machen jetzt 16 gig mit da rein habe ich halt 8 gig
unten 16 Gig drin, Riegel. Wen juckt's?
Zack. So, erledigt.
Next.
Einkaufsliste.
Einkaufsliste gucken.
Oh, jetzt wird's noch teurer.
Okay, es wird noch teurer, Leute.
Ich habe 3x
10 Terabyte Platten.
Aus dem alten Nass.
Die will ich in das neue packen.
3x 10 Terabyte
könnte man sagen, man macht jetzt 0,5.
Mir persönlich, ich möchte aber gar keinen RAID 5 mehr.
Ich habe hier heute Morgen erklärt warum.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich umsteigen auf einen RAID 1.
Das dumme ist, bei einem RAID 1 mit 10T hast du halt nur, also mit zwei Platten, zwei Platten RAID 1.
Hast halt nur 10TB.
10TB, denke ich mal, wird mir zum größten Teil reichen, aber mehr wäre schon ganz nice.
zum beispiel der dritten ct platte mache keine ahnung jetzt ist das ding über als
er ja überall zfz war zfz soll man ja auch ein paar prozente noch frei lassen
dass das besser performt ja wenn ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen aber ich
Komm eh nicht an die Grenze.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Festplatten.
Gibt es eigentlich noch gute
Hardware zum
Schacken, oder wie das hieß?
Habt ihr schon mal eine Festplatte geschackt?
Geschuckt?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Chat, habt ihr schon mal eine Festplatte geschuckt?
Schacking.
Schacken, ich glaube, das schaut schon wieder ein Schacken aus.
Hat sich schon mal eine Festplatte geschackt?
Ihr werft es.
Damit ist gemeint, man nimmt aus einem externen HDD-Gehäuse,
was vom Hersteller quasi als externe Festplatte verkauft wird,
das macht man auf und macht daraus die Platte raus und benutzt sie dann als interne Platte.
Weil die Hersteller diese Dinger teilweise günstiger verkaufen,
als es die normalen Platten
ähm
gibt.
Du hast welche geschuckt? Nice.
Genau.
Und viele Platten, das habe ich auch gehört,
die haben keinen SATA mehr, die sind intern einfach
dann direkt drauf gelötet.
Auf das Board
für die USB-Connection.
Da hat man dann gelitten.
Okay, lasst uns mal gucken, ob ich arm werden
würde, wenn ich mir eine ordentliche Platte kaufe.
Was machen eigentlich meine
Stonks? Mal gucken. Chat, Chat,
Chat. Mal kurz gucken, ob ich mir das alles hier überhaupt leisten kann.
Ne, Blödsinn. Ich verkaufe keine Stonks
dafür, nur dass ich mir eine Festplatte kaufen kann.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, als würde ich
dazu wenig...
Mein Arbeitgeber überweist mir schon genug im Monat. Ich kann mir auch so eine
Festplatte leisten. Aber trotzdem mal kurz gucken,
was die Stonks
machen.
Ho!
Nicht schlecht.
Stonks All World ETF letztes Jahr knapp 10%.
Ja, und der restliche Tagesgeld stellt 2,1% über das letzte Jahr.
Also von jetzt bis Zeitjahr.
Also quasi von jetzt bis März 2025.
Das ist doch eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Wie groß ist mein Portfolio?
Das ist nicht groß.
Ich habe genau
ein ETF. Fertig.
Oder du meinst in der Summe?
Das
werde ich nicht im Stream groß an die
große Glocke hängen.
sechsstellig ja wie viel prozent der wie gesagt letztes jahr hat anscheinend der
etf 95 und 9,6 knapp 9,6 prozent gemacht
Also ich habe zwei Sachen, ich habe den World ETF und so eine Art Tagesgeld.
Fertig.
So, also.
Chat, mal gucken.
Was ist denn die beste Platte preis-leistungstechnisch?
Preis pro Terabyte
Schnapper
Richtiger Schnapper
160 Kik für 152 Euro
Ja was ist denn mit euch los, Alter?
Warum existiert sowas überhaupt?
Für irgendwelche Retro-Geschichten, oder?
Für was anderes kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen
Das ist bestimmt sogar IDE noch.
IDE-Festplatte.
Nee, ist es nicht. Das ist SATA.
Hast du den Post von dem Typ gelesen,
der in die USA geflogen ist, um
30, 28 Terabyte-Platten
zu kaufen? Der Kram ist mittlerweile so
teuer, dass sich das wahrscheinlich lohnt, in die
USA zu fliegen dafür.
guck mal, das sind so Refurbished-Platten.
Seagate Exos 28 TB.
Refurbished.
Das Ding ist halt bei...
Was bedeutet eigentlich genau
Recertified in dieser...
in dieser Kombination?
Weil...
Was Certified?
Wie Certified?
Also...
100% Haltbarkeit haben die auf gar keinen Fall mehr.
Die liefen ja wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Jahre.
Smart wurde zurückgesetzt.
Genau, sowas denke ich mir nämlich auch.
Ein Test gemacht und alles auf Null gesetzt.
Okay, ja, das ist halt...
War erstmal halt nett, ne?
Aber es ist halt schon, ganz ehrlich,
so günstig kriegst du sonst K28T.
Das ist einmal Händler recertified und einmal Factory recertified.
Was ist das jetzt genau?
Easy Notebooks und Notebooks.de.
Das ist der gleiche Laden da hinter oder was?
das ist eine re zertifiziert und das bedeutet
das ist vom händler die certifizierte das ist doch die gleiche das ist doch die gleich der
gleiche shop ist das das sieht das sieht doch schon so ähnlich aus nur da kaufen fünf jahre
garantie bekommt ja so teuer wie festplatten mittlerweile sind ganz
ehrlich hast schon erst recht
aber die heißen die rezertifiziert und haben trotzdem nur ein jahr garantiert
hast du über deine firma corporate benefits wenn ja kannst du im western
nicht still mit 20 rabatt einkaufen dann die externen günstig kaufen kann man
jedoch schuppen die externen
ja welche welche denn was ist wie früher gab es diese wd my book oder wie diese
dinge hießen etwas mit book ja wie die mai book 22
schock
ok ok hier ist was drin ist
Okay, da brauchen wir
irgendwelches Spezialzeug.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja,
SMR suckt.
Das will ich nicht haben.
Ich glaube, vielleicht soll ich doch mal
Geld ausgeben.
Lass mal gucken.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch hier Gescheites?
WD Purple Pro.
Warum haben die denn so...
WD Purple, WD Red.
Die können sich auch nicht entscheiden, oder?
Okay.
WD, HDD, Colors.
Explained.
Okay, dann erklärt mal.
Purple ist für Surveillance.
Okay, also quasi für Continuous Rides.
also was haben hier blue robots hard drive for the money applications oder titel edition
start wherever you work also stücken normale so red für nass ja aber wie gesagt ich schreibe
ja da eh nichts großartig drauf.
Also es ist jetzt ja nicht so,
dass ich da
übelst viel I.O.
drauf machen würde.
Da wird
nachts Backup drauf gemacht und fertig.
Smart, so wäre ja das
vielleicht eher nett.
Enterprise Crate.
Gamer Storage. Wahrscheinlich ist
da unten drunter doch bei
Bei 3 von 4 ist es eh der gleiche Krempel.
Also, lass mal kurz weiter gucken.
26T
Barracuda weiß ich auch.
Die sind auch nicht sonderlich beliebt.
Seagate Iron Wolf Pro
28T
700 Euro
Das heißt, wenn ich mir zwei Stück davon kaufen würde
Für einen Raid 1
Bin ich einfach 1400 Euro los
Und wenn ich mir grad drei davon kaufen würde
Bin ich 2100 Euro los
Das klingt ein bisschen nach
Pepo Burn Money, oder?
Aber immerhin bei Mindfactory,
da weiß man, Mindfactory gehört das jetzt nicht zu
Heise, die haben das doch gekauft,
da war doch was.
Was war denn...
Das war ja der hässlichste Spinner, den ich je gesehen habe
bisher.
Der da gerade war.
Wollte ich mal aufmachen.
Jetzt gibt es keinen Spinner mehr.
Aber das sah schon hässlich aus, der Spinner.
Ähm.
Ja, vielleicht.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht mache ich das.
So, also.
28 T. Gut.
Oder
Oder für 100 Euro weniger
Die 24T
Ja 24T
Würde mir ehrlich gesagt auch reichen
Oh guck mal
Die ist sogar ein bisschen gesunken
Leute jetzt jetzt einkaufen hier
Muss es denn wirklich 16 TB sein?
Moment, Moment, 24.
Also ich hatte schon
defekte
HDDs. Ich hatte aber glaube ich
noch nie eine defekte SSD.
Weder NVMe noch normal.
BA-Computer
Kennt den jemand?
Kennt jemand BA-Computer?
Noch nie gehört
Moment, in Österreich
Verschenken die überhaupt nach Deutschland?
Wir sind versandt nach Deutschland
20% Mehrwertsteuer
Oh
Ja, aber Mindfactory lohnt sich das ja schon mal nett.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin mir da echt...
Ich bin mir da echt unsicher.
also so blöd klingt irgendwie tendiere ich ein bisschen zu der dann habe ich
auch genug speicher 28 da brauchst du einen tag bis sie die folge geschrieben
hast mein factory die wurden von heise gekauft für linux isos natürlich
natürlich immer immer linux isos wahrscheinlich braun und bruchteil des
speichers ich habe ja nichts großartig drauf außer backup stelle also mein plan
ist meine ganzen vor ems und sachen liegen ja auf der ssd 2 informiert dass dies auf die platten
kommt nur nächtlicher backup von eben diesen und halt von meinem desktop rechner und sowas
der held 28 t doch sehr lange gibt es eigentlich ein lichtblick wann die preise wieder runtergehen
Ich sehe da jetzt erstmal nichts.
Okay, Leute, ich glaube, ich glaube...
Ja, komm.
Ich meine, ich kaufe jetzt hier eh nichts.
Also nicht on stream direkt.
Ich überlege ja nur, was ich kaufe.
Ich will es einfach mal kurz...
Festplatten-Einbauservice.
Nee.
Ich will es einfach nur mal schwarz auf weiß kurz sehen, Chat.
Wenn man davon drei Stück kauft...
das ist mehr als manche leute für kompletten pc ausgeben
paypal money
das ist mehr als leute im monat verdienen ja
aber leute ich kann es mir diesen monat easy leisten ich krieg diesen monat bonus
bonuszahlung das sind ungefähr so pima daumen 8000 euro
überwiesen kriege ich die
die warte mal jetzt erzähle ich scheiße die kriege ich nicht überwiesen da muss
man steuern drauf bezahlen das wäre auch zu einfach kriegt ihr nicht
überwiesen schwachsinn 8000 euro bonus und da muss man steuern drauf bezahlen
also kriege ich dann irgendwie keine ahnung 4000 euro oder so überwiesen plus
das normale gehalt da kann ich mir auch ein paar festplatten kaufen
Das ist Jahresbonus.
Und das für Teilzeit.
Also ich kann mich echt nicht beschweren.
Für das Nas.
und für das Nass.
Okay, ich lasse die hier mal drinnen,
dass ich mich immer mal wieder daran erinnern kann,
wie scheiß teuer Festplatten sind.
Bestellt.
Wird am 4.3. erwartet.
Ja gut, dann könnte ich auch noch mitleben.
So.
Lass die bitte noch als Geschenk verpacken.
Kostet das 3,90?
Ja.
Und dann soll ich euch spenden, Chat?
Okay, machen wir weiter. Gehen wir auf Amazon.
So, was ich brauche? Ich brauche unbedingt neue Schuhe.
Was ich für Schuhe mag, sind die hier.
Das ist das Beste.
das problem ist ich will die schuhe in extra weit weil ich weil ich weiter fuß
habe white people happy gibt sie dann gibt sie dann in extra gibt sie denn
extra weit hier kann man kann man überhaupt die größe auswählen bin ich
bin ich blöd ach ihr größe extra weit
44 EU extra weit.
Top.
Die gibt es nur in dieser?
Sind die sicher, dass das extra weit ist?
Weil ich bilde mir eigentlich ein,
dass es diese Schuhe nur in schwarz-weiß gibt in extra weit.
Deutschland. Ich muss das mal umstellen.
Auf
USA.
Ja.
Alter Webseite, Mann.
Funktionier halt.
Ein Viertel Festplatte, ja.
Gehlenimus 28.
So, und wenn ich jetzt
hier gucke,
äh, width. Moment, da gibt es
es gibt noch nicht mal extra weit.
Selbst im offiziellen
Shop in den USA nicht.
Ich glaube, das stimmt nicht,
die Anzeige, dass die extra weit sind.
Obwohl,
das witzigerweise
ist es in US.
Das ist ein US-Import.
Ist immer noch
D-E-O-E-N? Wirklich?
Alter.
United States.
Wie switch ich denn da hin?
Geht das nicht, oder was?
Nein, ich will die Seite von den USA haben.
Warum kann ich da nicht hin switchen?
Ich hab doch schon auf Englisch geklickt, Chat.
Hier kann ich auf das Land klicken.
Okay, pass auf.
Äh, US.
Aha.
Trick 17.
Ach, so läuft der Gel.
Cumulus 28.
Okay, Filter.
Breite.
Extra White.
White people happy?
Gell, Nimbus X, die sehen so aus.
Doch, Chat.
Den gibt es, ich dachte, den gibt es nur in Schwarz-Weiß sonst.
Okay, was?
Rein von der Optik her.
Was würde euch mehr zusagen?
Der hier oder der Schwarz-Weiße?
Richtiges Hacker-Zeug, ne?
Schwarz-Weiß?
Mir auch, mir auch
Aber ganz ehrlich, meine Schuhe sind so extrem durchgelaufen mittlerweile
Ich brauch zackig neue
Dass ich sagen würde
Den gibt's hier nicht in Schwarz-Weiß
Dann nehm ich den halt in dieser komischen Farbe
Mir egal, ob der dreckig wird
Ich kann auch mit dreckigem Schuh rennen
import charges in klub
erst alles teuer geworden 211 euro für ein paar schuhe aber da weiß ich dass die gut
passen ich habe die gleichen schuhe jetzt schon eine ganze weile aber halt nicht die
28er sondern irgendwie 26 oder so und die sind so gut die sind sowas von durchgelaufen
mittlerweile. Mir tut schon die Ferse weh, wenn ich da drin renne.
Äh, das geht.
Zack.
RAM und Schuhe.
Wird schon eine teure Angelegenheit.
So.
Dann.
Da habe ich letztens auf Amazon
was ganz Gutes, ganz gut Günstiges gesehen.
äh, SFP Plus Module
bräuchte ich nochmal so eine Hand voll
und da gab es recht
günstige Packages mittlerweile hier
Bestseller, ja
irgendwie 11 Euro noch was, oder was ist denn
59 durch 4
14,75 Euro pro Modul
ist preislich wirklich in Ordnung
aber Chat meint hier
diese komischen No-Name-Dinger, da kann man sich
drauf verlassen oder sacken die einfach richtig
hart rein
Meint ihr, das taugt?
Jetzt kommen die Leute, die sagen, bestell
FS.com. Okay, okay.
Moment. Moment, das sind die
falschen. Die meine
ich doch gar nicht.
Ich meine die
mit RJ45-Stecker.
Haben wir da nicht letztens auch mal irgendwie einen 10er-Pack oder sowas gefunden, der recht günstig war?
Ja, da wird es schon teuer hier.
Ist RTL 8127 nicht zu günstig, noch SFP zu... Ich will gar keine SFP machen.
mein switch hat halt recht viele sp plus ports und ich brauche ein paar kupfer
ports und da sind solche adapter besser als den ganzen switch zu kaufen
werden heiß ja nicht heiß werden
pack of one pack ist auch geil auf worden
Okay, das geht hier halbwegs
87 Euro
Durch 4
21 Euro
Pro Transceiver
Das ist okay
Was sind denn das hier?
Sind das irgendwelche billig No-Name-Dinger?
Queen
Kennt das jemand?
Okay, gucken wir mal hier, was das hier kostet
so produkte optische transziver eigentlich streng genommen nicht ich
will vernetzung wo muss ich suchen kupfer systeme
ich suche einfach jetzt
Ups.
Meine Augen, Chat.
Äh.
Okay, ich geh jetzt hier einfach mal
hier hin und dann tipp ich da
optische, optische Transziver.
Ne, wofür?
Boah, fuck.
Vernetzung vielleicht?
Aber die Suche ist schon mal Paintschamp, ne?
Wo find ich, wo find ich denn?
Das steht bestimmt unter optische Transsiever, oder?
Ich suche...
Hier, mit RJ45-Stecker.
Genau sowas such ich hier.
Sowas, mit RJ45-Stecker.
Allerdings sind die Dinger halt von Cisco krass teuer.
Äh, Modelle?
T?
SR?
Äh.
T, oder?
Das ist dann mit dem R45-Stecker.
Ja.
Boah.
Alter.
Warum sind die so teuer?
Oder sind das mehrere?
Das sind wahrscheinlich Francisco-Module.
Die sind übertrieben teuer.
Ne.
Das ist ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist mir zu teuer.
das ist einer ja also dann probiere ich weiß nicht mal das ist die dinger was
was für den hersteller ist eine queen die jackie jack was wir immer mich
überhaupt aus ist eine marke die sich auf hochwertige jaja die antizien so
hochwertig dass sie nicht meine webseite haben die haben nicht meine webseite
leute die haben nicht meine webseite das ist bestimmt der china chinesen
trojaner gleich mit im sfp plus modul
Ukraine hat Switche?
Äh, ja, die würde ich,
die 10G-Tech, die habe ich auch
geguckt.
Die sind aber noch ein Ticken
teurer.
Ist das hier
Dings sind das das oft kap alter
Das hier ist 10 g tech
Number of Items, 8.
Boah.
Die Dinger sind so brutal teuer.
Ganz ehrlich, diese Billigdinger, die taugen glaube ich nichts.
Ich mag das Ukraine Zeug auch, ja.
Ja.
Nee, Chat, da kann ich mich gerade nicht
dazu durchringen, hier von
gut Glück welche zu kaufen.
WTF,
warum ist das so günstig?
10G. Ach, das ist
ein 1Gig SSP Plus Modul, okay.
Ja, geil.
Gibt es eigentlich,
gibt es sowas mit 2,5
Gig? Also ich weiß, die 10G
können 2,5, ja.
Aber so explizit billiger und dann mit
2,5?
er schon teurer kram schon teuer da kann ich gar nicht zu durchregen und billig
billig ding keine ahnung wenn der hersteller nicht meine webseite hat
da habe ich da vertraue ich dann doch zu wenig dass das dass es taugt ja
so dann brauche ich noch weil ich immer ordentlich alles aufräumen will ich hier
so sortierboxen so irgendwie so was ja so dinge hier sieht doch kistenberg doch gar nicht schlecht
aus flex optik
das ist das sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus guck mal das hat sogar
noch so zwischen dinger man könnte natürlich auch mal gucken dass man die
besser stapeln kann was es als l box gibt alles so
so als teile des zeuges der box alles alles l box kompatibel ist halt abfakt
teuer weil l box und als profi kram vermarktet
und dann auch stabil ja so so so was jedoch gar nicht schlecht da gibt es zehn stück
den stück mit die weih dass dabei sie so unter teil dinger ich trug mir doch so was
selbst das dauert doch stunden und sind nicht so stabil am ende nach stabil vielleicht schon
aber nicht so nicht so nicht so schön am ende wie diese boxen vor allem 3d druck das war mit
einem deckel und dem scharnier und allem eingekauft für bastelstelle also dass das
jetzt, weil ich demnächst mal hier ordentlich
wieder aufräumen will und alles schön sortieren.
Da brauche ich... Wisst ihr was?
Irgendwie sprechen mich die Dinger an.
Die Lieferung
braucht länger als der Druck.
Nee. Wenn ich mir
10 solcher Boxen, ich weiß ja, also je nachdem
wie groß die sind, die selber drucke,
dann brauche ich länger als Amazon.
Guck mal. Amazon ist...
Am Mittwoch
sind die da.
Stanley von denen habe ich welche von denen habe ich hier an der Wand an den die haben auch solche
dinger der sort master er so dinge davon habe ich von denen an der wand hängen zwei stück das
ganz nice.
Stanley Swordmaster.
Das sieht aber mal ganz, ganz, ganz stark nach
Kistenberg aus, oder?
Nur in Gelb.
Und, also, ich gehe
davon aus, dass die dort
sich abgeguckt haben.
Die sind pock.
Kostet aber auch eine Kiste 24 Euro
Kann man die raus?
Ach, da sind so
Körbchen schon drinnen
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist es mit diesen
Dividern deutlich lieber
Weil dann kann ich selbst einstellen
Wie groß die einzelnen Abteile sind
Die heißen Fat Max
Pepo Fat
ich bestelle mir eine paket 10 10er park kistenberg ist kistenberg ist doch bestimmt auch in china
chinesen ding auch wenn es nicht so heißt kistenberg okay oder auch nicht
oder auch nicht kistenberg bei groß per plast was ist groß war plast polen
okay kein china chinesen zeug macht macht macht bei mir schon mal plus
punkte ist ein berg die haben guten namen okay gut haben wir was brauche ich noch
ich brauche noch zwei direkte touch kabel aber bevor ich mir die bestelle suche ich erst noch
mal bei mir im server raum deine unter irgendeiner ecke was liegt noch ach ja
für weitere bastel kram nvm ssd passive cooler aber welche die die wirklich
schmal sind. Die Dinger sind hier wahrscheinlich
alle ein bisschen zu fett.
Sowas hier ist nicht übel.
Bei 4, bei
5 Prozent. Ja, war toll.
Die könnten mir ein bisschen
hoch sein, ehrlich gesagt.
Lass mal kurz vergleichen, wie hoch die sind.
Ja, das ist definitiv zu hoch.
der bauer hat ein jahr aber die sind wahrscheinlich auch ganz schön teuer
der bauer hat ein das heißt es ist ein thermal chris lee oder was was ich plane zu bauen gar
nichts aber ich habe festgestellt dass entfall passivkühler sehr nice sind für die ssd
temperaturen und die kriegt jetzt einfach jede neue ssd bei mir zum ding drauf sofern nicht
das Mainboard.
Das ist ja der abgedrehtesten Aussehen
der SSD-Kühler ever.
Ach, da ist noch
ein Lüfter drin.
Leute, wollen wir wetten?
Der Lüfter ist brutalst laut.
Thermal Grizzly.
Der Auer.
Der Acht Auer.
Das sieht ja richtig schnörkellos aus.
Ich hab gedacht, was da sonst noch so am Start ist.
Wie hoch ist denn das Ding?
Steht das irgendwo?
Ein Zentimeter hoch.
Okay, und die Dinger, die sind halt deutlich niedriger.
Klotrenz.
Alles klar, wer kennt die nicht?
Ich suche halt welche, die wirklich flach sind.
Guck mal.
Die sind halt nur 0,3 cm.
Die sind wahrscheinlich nicht so geil.
Alte Netzwerkkarte, an was ihr mich erinnern sollt.
Tja.
Chat, ich weiß noch, dass ich das gesagt habe.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, um was es ging.
Aber vielleicht haben wir das schon gemacht heute Morgen.
Ich brauch Flache.
Dass die auch in Mini-PC-Sachen so ordentlich rein...
...passen.
Ähm...
Ne, ich bestell mir davon...
Ich bestell mir davon noch zwei.
Scheiß drauf.
Du hast die und hast die Temps ca. 20 Grad.
das sind ja auch so ähnliche dinger der elute store welt welt bekannter
hersteller elute enten wer kennt elute eng nicht
ich habe ja schon was also diese dinger die sind ohne lüfter ohne lüfter ohne
lüfter das passt der chinesische 20 cm deutsches deutscher stahl oder was hat
er immer erzählt 25 cm 30 ich glaube ist ja was ist ja was ich probiere das mal
aus ich probiere mal die gibt es auch als kupfer aber aber flach nämlich lieber die komme ich
bestellen wir auch noch mal ein elut eng und dann gucken wir mal was besser ist da kommen
wir bestellen hier von ein wir bestellen davon davon dass fünfer packen davon dass zweier pack
Und dann gucken wir mal, was besser ist.
Eloteng oder
Clotrenz.
Klingt eins beschissener als das andere, Alter.
Can't wait.
Oh, sowas könnte ich in der Tat auch gebrauchen.
Das sieht aus wie ein externes SSD-Enclosure.
Externes SSD-Enclosure.
oh ja
add to basket
haben wir auch gebraucht
so und dann brauche ich noch
ich brauche eigentlich noch 2-3 Sachen, aber das kriegen wir heute nicht mit
ich brauche ein
fake edit
HDMI
so, ihr werdet wahrscheinlich
nicht wissen, was das ist, das werde ich euch gleich erklären
genau, sowas
guck mal, das ist so
ein dummy plug, trifft es eigentlich
Das ist ein Dummy für einen HDMI-Ausgang. Damit kann man, wenn man beispielsweise keinen Monitor anschließen will, so einen Dummy-Plug reinmachen. Dann denkt die andere Seite, es ist ein Monitor dran angeschlossen und schaltet es nicht ab. Oder sagt, ach guck mal, der Monitor unterstützt ja 240 Hertz oder sowas.
Ein Problem habe ich dabei jetzt.
Bevor ich das bestelle...
Also ich habe noch genau im Kopf, ich brauche das.
Mein Problem ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr wofür.
Mir fällt es nicht ein wofür.
Da sieht es hässlich aus.
was haben wir hier dummy plug 1000 bestellen einfach nochmal ukraine
braucht man für ipo
auch was was ist was hier kann ich jetzt ja verhofft machen wer weiß was das ist
das ist ja der ist ja so lustig alle
Ja, komm.
Nochmal Ukraine.
Was haben wir denn hier jetzt alles?
Ukraine, Ukraine.
Glotrans und
Elu-Teng.
Das klingt...
Wisst ihr, wie beides klingt?
Habt ihr mal Age of Empires 2 gespielt?
Das klingt wie
Voice Lines auf Age of Empires 2.
Klo-Trends, Klo-Trends, Elu-Teng, Klo-Trends.
Das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen, wie das in Age of Empires 2 irgendwelche Villager sagen oder so.
Elu-Teng, Elu-Teng, Klo-Trends.
Das ist irgendwie, was weiß ich, Zivilisation aus, keine Ahnung, wo man so spricht.
Faceman, ja, ja, versteht man.
Okay, also, was kost's?
480 Euro.
Bam.
Dazu kommen noch die Festplatten und Zeug.
Wobei ich die aber nicht bei Amazon bestelle.
Ja, dann.
Würde ich sagen.
Ich brauche zwar noch ein paar Dinge, aber ich muss jetzt auf Chat.
Entweder machen wir noch einen Einkaufsstream morgen.
Oder morgen machen wir Stellenanzeigen.
Oder irgendwelches Nassgebastel oder irgendwas.
Sollen wir mal gucken.
aber jetzt muss ich leider oft chat gehen sehr schön dass ihr alle mit am
start war zweimal heute im stream so zahlreich erschienen seid wer noch nicht
gefoltert hat kann es an der stelle ja gerne machen
guck noch mal dass ich nicht wieder subscription übersehen habe weil ich ja
gerne mache
Will der Igel? Das habe ich gesehen, Freund.
Michael, 50 Billiarden.
Hat auch wieder resubscribed, Freund.
Excellent.
Ja, dann gehe ich jetzt off.
Jetzt bist du erst da.
Ja, schlechtes Timing.
Aber ich muss jetzt off.
Wir machen nochmal kurz die VM aus
Power off
Und dann
Sehen wir uns
Wahrscheinlich morgen
Und wenn morgen nicht, dann auf jeden Fall im nächsten Stream
Bis dann Leute
Wir sehen uns, macht's gut, CU